[Music]
welcome to part two of this seven part
mini series
in which we visualize the paths taken by
the various key figures during the
events of the great calamity if you
haven't watched the previous part which
covers link and zelda
be sure to check that one out first as
we will skip some of the introduction
established in that part
in this episode i will be joined by
hyrulegamer we have been wanting to
collaborate for a while now and fate
once again meddled with our plans when
hyrule warrior's age of calamity was
unexpectedly announced
however we will persevere so i decided
to cover this one with him at my side
after you're done watching this video be
sure to head over to his channel and
check out his video about the unseen
parts from breath the wild which we will
see in their prime in age of calamity
as always a link will be in the
description and in the end card
just like last time we will be pausing
the narrative at specific moments to
inject a suggestion for a possible
gameplay section
now without further ado let's jump right
back into it
as soon as rivali witnessed the honors
of the calamity from afar and reported
ganon's return to the rest of the party
the first priority for the four pilots
was of course to make their way to each
of their respective divine beasts
arbosa tags along with lincoln zelda
through the promenade the canyons and
then kakariko village
still accompanied by lincoln zelda they
make their way down to sahasrara slow at
which point she parts ways with the hero
and princess
her goal is to meet up with van the
boris who is located in the vast sancy
of her home province the gerudo desert
which isn't exactly close especially on
foot
when link and zelda turn right at the
bottom of the sahasrara slope
erbosa takes the left path across the
aegis bridge
from there she treks past battery lake
and takes the allen bridge to reach the
east point and
subsequently moves west along the foot
of the great plateau
past the other outposts located there
it's safe to say that the paths the
champions will traverse towards their
divine beasts will be important
and depicted for gameplay the many
outposts which span across the edge of
the great plateau played a crucial role
during the calamity as it is for here
that the evacuation line towards forte
tenno was made possible
with soldiers creating a defensive line
and keeping the fleeing citizens safe in
the process
since herbosa crossed right through this
section it is possible that she played
an important role in helping to defend
the outposts well
on her way to vanda boris although it is
likely too early at this point for any
guardians to have arrived here
we have seen that monsters such as the
coblins and moblins also took part in
the attack
in breath of the wild the ruins of these
outposts are crawling with monsters
so it's not too far-fetched to assume
that the initial defense of the outposts
was against monsters
rather than guardians after potentially
assisting the hylians at the outposts
urbosa continues on her way to gerudo
desert she follows the road that passes
by the great plateau
then heads south across the dig dog
suspension bridge
and into gerudo canyon pass from there
she moves through the grudo canyon to
make her way towards the desert gerudo
canyon is a path without any branching
paths
there's a good chance that this will be
a playable section as well
since it's a great way to force a linear
style of battling your way through the
narrow canyon
if the previous scenario turns out to be
true and herbosa did indeed help with
the defense of the outposts at the great
plateau this would also justify the
presence of guardians inside the canyon
as by this point they could have arrived
this far from the castle in pursuit of
verbosa
and her divine beast now this is where
we come to a point where the game might
ignore some of the information provided
by creating a champion
and comes up with its own version of
events in the age of calamity trailer we
see her
fighting yiga clan members in gerudo
town not only that but she's wearing her
blue champion's cloth while doing it
something she didn't receive until right
before the great calamity
i think it's unlikely that herbosa would
take such a massive detour only to
return to spectacle rock afterwards
getting to her divine beast is the main
objective and of utmost importance in
the strategy to fight ganon
with this possible inconsistency we are
going to cover two different options
both of which have evidence supporting
it option one would be that the attack
on gerudo town despite the presence of
the champion's cloth
still takes place before the calamity at
the very least one day before
since on the actual day of the calamity
she's at the promenade nowhere close to
the gerudo region
in this case the path laid out by
creating a champion stays true
she moves up the quarry at the end of
the canyon and straight up the spectacle
rock
this section would probably still fall
under the gameplay scenario mentioned
earlier
where you fight your way through the
canyon then up to quarry and towards
vanoborus
the evidence supporting this lies in the
many dead guardians found at both the
quarry and atop the mountains on the way
to spectacle rock
the only thing working against it is the
fact that they are also found way beyond
spectacle rock on the other side
of the mountains close to the lommei
labyrinth option two would be that the
attack on gerudo town does take place
during the calamity if this is indeed
true we have to come up with a
possibility as to why urbosa would
travel all the way out here rather than
to spectacle rock when there's so little
time to lose
in which case i proposed that vana boris
may not be located on spectacle rock
initially but rather close to gerudo
town
and this would make sense since nobody
knew when ganon was going to show up
and in the days and weeks before the
champions had been practicing to get
their beasts under control
spectacle rock isn't exactly the most
ideal location to do this since its peak
is quite narrow with very little room
for movement
instead it would be more effective to
use the huge open space of the desert to
perform these kinds of exercises
it's also noteworthy that in this memory
we actually see vonne boris parked in
the desert which gives some credence to
this theory
but i want to reiterate that if the
attack on gerudo town indeed takes place
before the great calamity
starts then the next gameplay scenario
is basically useless
and we can just skip right to vanna
boris on spectacle rock
with this new path in mind urbosa makes
her way to her divine beast only to
realize that garuda town is under yiga
attack
while her task as pilot of vanna boris
is crucial she is also the chief of
gerudo
as such she probably wouldn't leave her
people to their fate and
may decide to join the battle briefly to
help defend their home and keep the
civilians out of harm's way
after disposing of most of the yiga and
letting the gerudo army take care of the
rest she boards van the boris and takes
her up to spectacle rock
with her powerful laser ready to take
aim and fire ganon uses his malice to
corrupt van the boris
trapping urbosa inside to make matters
worse the malice which infects the giant
machine
manifests into the monstrous phantom
we've come to know is thunder blight
ganon
we could put this next part up as a
possible gameplay scenario but i think
it's pretty
safe to say that this won't be necessary
it would be very strange if the actual
fight between
urbosa and thunder blight wasn't
playable so we're just going to assume
it will be
and we all know how this is going to end
after a fierce battle between the
phantom and champion herbosa is
eventually bested by ganon's puppet and
killed in the process
her spirit is trapped within the walls
of the very machine she was destined to
pilot
here she will linger for the next 100
years
arbosa's crow fate is just one of the
many sad moments awaiting us in age of
calamity
she fought valiantly and gave it her all
but the unexpected turn of events at the
hands of calamity ganon caught her off
guard
and it won't be until 100 years later
when link wakes up that she will finally
get the chance to take revenge on the
monster which took her life away
so unexpectedly
[Music]
hmm
you